[Music]
and uh here we are and actually i want
to thank first of all i want to
i i meant to start off the episode this
way but i wanted to thank
the academy for all the grammy noms that
we got this year
yeah yeah i don't know if you saw but
tiny meat gang was nominated for
uh year song of the year song of the
year and then we had best score of the
year as well for a film
mm-hmm because our song was in um
the tax collector yep it's opened with
walkman
if you remember that yeah when shia
labeouf walks out yeah it's like
burnt wheat and good
good i'm a fat man
it was so creeper and so i wanted to
thank the academy
and i know the weekend got snubbed but
um i'm sorry man sorry we had to do it
to you
yeah it's because they gave us so many
[ __ ] noms
so it's crazy how we got um
nominated four times for performance of
the year that was pretty crazy
yeah that was that was nuts i mean they
really really like us at the academy
you saw denzel going off on twitter
denzel
uh curry courier what did he say i saw
something about how he's like not angry
anymore
i i'm i'm i thousand percent feel like
feel what he's saying in some capacity
basically he's just [ __ ] frustrated
he
i feel him in that i think he's going
through it
i like it seems like the pandemic is
really
[ __ ] with his head a little bit why
what was he saying
he just feels um this part is is
specific to him this is not the part i
related to but he's you know
he feels he doesn't get uh credit for
the work he puts in he feels like he's
he's put out a ton of solid music and
and no one really
acknowledges it or talks about it and
he's kind of saying
he plans on making music to
with the intention of making hits next
year and how his whole style
just is kind of snubbed you know you
don't know
people don't really care about uh people
don't pay try
don't talk as much about you know sort
of conscious and focused rap music and
stuff and
he he he's in a better headspace i think
now and
and um but yeah i just i just felt for
the guy because i
actually you know i agree with a lot of
what he was saying in that i think he is
a great artist and i think he's done a
lot of good stuff and
i can imagine how frustrating that would
be because if
i had made some of the music he had made
i would feel very good about myself as
an artist and
so that's all yeah huh
well uh so you said wait he said he's
gonna go to making hits
no he just kind of said he's like you
know what watch like next year i'm gonna
have billboard hits i'm you know i'm
gonna make tracks that you know
um yeah this was like from his first
rant which is a bit more bitter and i
think he's just angry
so i think maybe he's just feeling that
he has more to give and
in his mind he's kind of like all right
you want to see [ __ ] that's a bit more
mainstream you know
not as hyper creative and artistic fine
i can do that too
bam and and so huh maybe we'll get some
of that out of denzel but it's crazy
he's been reading too many negative
comments dude
so it is that's what it is man he's on
his own youtube videos
sorting by sorting by newest on on
youtube
[ __ ] you no honestly because um he's
[ __ ] great all the music he makes is
fantastic and people
love him people love him a new track
drops ever
like people are like dude denzel never
[ __ ] misses he never misses because
he never does
he truly doesn't bro like i don't think
i've heard something by him where i go
oh that wasn't as good as that like i
feel every project feels
dumb unique yeah and focused and it has
a theme
and like [ __ ] zoo maybe people
you know don't agree with this but that
album zoo i think is just
dude speedboat has 40 million plays
and ricky has 70 million it's crazy that
you know he ca like the proof is in
what he's made and he still has that
feeling i just feel
i feel for him like that's got to be a
[ __ ] feeling to not feel accomplished
even though
he's very clearly accomplished yeah
yeah no i know and um this whole thing
he's like one of the guys he's like one
of those guys where no matter what song
there's always something interesting or
or with so much a rap
all like there's so many lyrics and
lines that are the same in every single
song
yep especially by generic rappers that
you know don't really care about what
they're writing but he
he gives funny references there's always
funny lines like it's like listening to
ski masks same thing it's like
you gotta you want to listen to the song
multiple times just because the flows
are really interesting and because
you didn't catch something that he said
which is pretty rare
i feel like in mainstream rap at least i
wouldn't say denzel's mainstream but he
is i mean he's 40 million 60 million 70
million like that's like
he's he's loved by a lot of people bro
he's got six million monthly listeners
off of
you know his his his
approach to making music is like a
thousand percent
creative oriented it's it's not you know
i'm gonna do a little creativity and
then i'll do something that a lot of
other
a lot the majority of people understand
to try to get them into this other [ __ ]
he's
super unapologetic about what he does
his music videos are [ __ ] dope like
it's just crazy that you know but but
maybe this is maybe this is the thing is
that
we're saying all this and it's it's nice
to hear that but maybe
you know the industry doesn't give him
looks which i can see him being
frustrated with yeah
that would make sense if this was more
of an industry complaint
but denzel if you ever hear this you're
the man bro
yeah that's all big fans here yeah major
um justin bieber posted something
to this yeah moving on to what a
transition
justin speaking of people we're fans of
i just thought this was kind of funny
maybe it's not funny maybe it maybe he's
got a point here
but i think that it's worth bringing up
he posted this on instagram he said to
the grammys
i am flattered to be acknowledged and
appreciated for my artistry
i am very meticulous and intentional
about my music with that being said i
set out to make an r b
album changes was and is an rmb album it
is not being acknowledged as an rmb
album which is very strange to me
i grew up admiring r b music and wished
to make a project that would embody that
sound for this not to be put into
into that category feels weird
considering from the chords to the
melodies to the vocal style all the way
down to the hip-hop drums
that were chosen chosen it is undeniably
unmistakably an r
b album shut up man
[Laughter]
you're fine but also fine
did you listen to it no it wasn't
it to me maybe i just don't know r b
music
i haven't listened to a lot of it
growing up but to me it wasn't r b
at all all right let me let me what like
what's like uh
the drums especially like it felt super
poppy and light all right what's the
album called
changes changes all right
all right what's uh what's a song i
could
oh yeah i listened to forever i i mean
listen i mean the one with the one with
um
with quavo is on that album
intentions how can you not say that's
how can you say that's not pop
i could see this being art now if ty
dolla sign was on this
you would have a different feel no dude
with those 808s the the
like the jumpy like boom
yeah yeah yeah right it's like it's not
made to like get into it like
r b supposed to be slower and like yeah
maybe i'm again maybe i'm completely
[ __ ] wrong
but like all the r b like listen i don't
know i think i think you're kind of
building off of like
um old like sort of
90s era rmb like
it it can skirt on those higher tempos
easy and and
um yeah uh
there are plenty of plenty of artists
that are in the r b category that
can't kind of do similar stuff like this
but yeah
i yeah i still agree with you though
that this song
skews a bit more pop definitely but
yump dude yummy that's not r b though
yeah
yeah it's not like a commercial dog come
on
i don't know i liked it i liked the
album i'm just saying i didn't think i
didn't think it was r b
but um why does he even care this guy
nominated for [ __ ] grammy has over
700 million play like dude they
you won them already yeah why do people
even give a [ __ ] about that stupid ass
award man
yeah i yeah i don't i don't really know
either
they this there's so much prestige for
some reason behind the grammys
it still carries so much weight to say
you're grammy nominated but it's like
every year they [ __ ] up so bad
dog they chose macklemore over kendrick
and
and and kanye and that's just one
example
i know and [ __ ] magna carta was in
the was in the
lineup i think that year as well like
off that one example alone yeah how
could you even
give a [ __ ] how did the weekend not get
one nomination
that's not crazy one just wild people
were talking about his [ __ ]
nonstop his um his most recent music
video
what's the title of the track i forget
it um
i don't know songs by names
it was uh released close to halloween
too late yeah okay too late that
that only has 10 million views everyone
is smoking
dust how is not everyone that's one of
the greatest music videos i've seen ever
yeah dude that was that's what i'm
talking about maybe he needs to be
nominated for an mtv music video award
or whatever because his music videos
this year have been top [ __ ] notch
unreal bro yes
so great yeah that's
[ __ ] up this video only has 10 million
views
yeah um
no no nothing i was just going to look
wait which one
uh it's too uh too late too late is the
name of that
[Music]
yeah you're right oh that's only from a
month ago though
i would have expected this video i don't
know how this wasn't on like
every director outlet
yeah until i bleed only has 11 million
that's pretty crazy maybe
people don't think it's as creative as i
did but
this video makes you feel like oh
that's [ __ ] well [ __ ] up
it's good dude like blinding lights has
347 million plays on just the
audio version on youtube
how did that not get anonymous
nomination show is stupid but
you know i'm crazy i'm happy freddie
gibbs got a nomination
yeah if he'll win you know that's
another story but
i'm very dope for anyone yeah he's
definitely deserving